okay so today is office move day which
means that I have to pack up all of
everything that I have over here and get
it elsewhere so this is gonna be fun
especially because I don't actually
think that this white table of mine is
that easy to disassemble so my plan is
to kind of take this white table which
to be honest I haven't been using too
much in this office and put it into the
other office and leave this black table
here entirely because I don't think that
this black table I mean it's it's I like
this one because it's bigger it's
height-adjustable like you can I can use
it as a standing desk whereas this one
here has just kind of been it's just I
don't know why I've been even using it
to be honest but I got the white one it
just just because but the problem with
this desk is that well it's from Ikea
and when I assembled it I had to like
yeah here it is I had to these little
things here all right let me show you
these little things here they like I had
to hammer them in and I'm not sure if I
can pull them out on what so that's
gonna be hopefully I can easily pull
them out and then I'll easily be able to
put them back in if so I'll be happy
because otherwise I don't know how I'm
gonna be able to transport this it's not
in my car at all
[Music]
well that's it wasn't really as hard as
I thought it would be these kind of
rivets just popped out with a
screwdriver pretty easily now the other
thing that I have to decide is what
exactly I want to keep from here and
carry into the new office so I obviously
still want to have some kind of setup
here at home because I won't always be
in the in your office I'm thinking or
just leaving this monitor here for that
purpose and then this I'm gonna take is
that's kind of my primary setup not sure
if I should take these monitors because
well I'm not gonna be playing any loud
music there obviously and for everything
maybe I can get something a bit smaller
I can keep this because this I usually
use for like music production and stuff
not really like I use it for editing as
well because they're here but it's a bit
overkill for just YouTube video editing
so maybe I'll leave them here at home
this has to come with us the printer I'm
not sure if we'll take the printer this
is an Alex draw unit from Ikea and
there's actually an identical one but
white at the new office already left
over from like the previous tenant so I
can keep that which is great this which
I haven't got a name for this plant yet
I think I'm gonna take that with us I
also wasn't sure what to do about the
100,000 subscriber YouTube award but I
think I'll leave that at home and just
because I really want that in the office
kind of precious to me I want to keep it
at home this stuff and man here's a lot
of stuff here this little grid unit
thing for Mike here there's an identical
one in the office but it's white and it
has another extra row on top so that I'm
gonna I don't have to take this with me
no but I will take my most of this stuff
here because it is like work-related
stuff and also the Cherno and the hazel
loggers they're gonna come with me as
well
I think that's about all the stuff that
I need to take so let's go ahead and
start loading this into the car
[Music]
just thought I'd do a little check-in so
I'm gonna call now and it is pretty
packed but me and my me and my bro here
are gonna we're gonna get this office
moved
[Music]
okay so here we are in the new office
everything is pretty much set up now and
by everything I mean the absolute you
know that I need to actually get any
work done there's a lot of reverb going
on which is like because it's places are
empty I've got a whole bunch of acoustic
foreign panels that I'm going to put
probably on some of the walls and
obviously as I move in more furniture
and stuff like that I think I should get
a lot better I guess I'll show you guys
a little bit of what has actually gone
into this space at the moment it's quite
a large space it's like 10 meters long
and a full meters wide I think I'm
definitely gonna spice gear set up some
kind of like creative space some kind of
like development studio maybe even like
a game development studio pretty
exciting progress here the thing that
I'm excited about Mars which is I think
I mentioned that several times before is
the fact that this is an office you know
it's not hard working from home for me
was quite a challenging experience I
think that this place is just gonna just
gonna make me be a lot more productive
than I was before
which I'm honestly really excited for
I'm with 2020 being in you here one of
the things I really want to do this year
is bring you guys along with me a lot
more than I have in the past I want to
share more of my life with you and I
want to share more of my work with you
and stuff that I might want to be
working on fun facts it's a public
holiday today sir old
like to get my coffin dramatis but to be
honest it's actually one of the things
that I definitely need to get in the
office as soon as possible is some kind
of way to make coffee I'm definitely not
going to get like an espresso machine or
anything like that I don't want to harm
and I don't really want a second one
here in the office but I'm thinking of
getting a chemical some kind of pour
about coffee think I'll keep you guys
updated with that any suggestions I'm
going to get just leave a comment below
cos I honestly have never done anything
like that before
Emma I've hardly ever made coffee with
an espresso machine sir you know one
other thing that I really want to get
here like it's always some kind of like
greenery plants and stuff like that
because I used to have a lot in my
office at home and this place obviously
no sir
yeah and I've to work something out
stuff as a little side note one of the
things I've been thinking about in this
new space is how I want to film my video
and I'm still kind of trying to figure
that out but one quick tip is always try
and shoot deep you can see how nice this
shot here looks well hopefully because
there's first of all a huge window right
here like literally massive and that's a
huge nice kind of softish light sources
here in my face making me pretty well
exposed but then also I'm shooting off
into the depth you can see all that
although wonderful bouquet I mean it's
probably going to kill I think it's that
like yeah I'm on I'm on a f/2 right now
but you know realistic that probably
want to shoot around something like this
maybe otherwise I think background
probably true blurry
anyway back to f/2 I think this set is
definitely going to evolve over the
coming weeks as I stopped you're
probably just stuck right now
you guys have any ideas what you put in
the office let me know in the comment
section below
still not really sure what I'm gonna do
with the place but I think there's a
bunch of stuff left our bars well
they're just like kind of wooden table
here that's kind of over - this probably
is not helping my sister Blair II anyway
cuz it would entail with here that I
know
these squares for Mike here as well that
is what bests here which is really cool
but I'm obviously going to another like
get on the drawers and stuff around this
chair was also just yeah so that's
pretty bold anyway
that's gonna wrap up I think it's almost
four o'clock it's actually 420 so it's a
possible clock
I'm probably gonna get hurt of the day
now but if you guys have any suggestions
for what you want to see in this new
office and if you want me to show
something specific or decorated in a
specific way leave a comment below I'll
be checking this out for inspiration and
that's about it I'll see you guys next
time
hope you enjoyed this video good bye
[Music]